[Musique]
on a toujours du mal à avouer une
qualité
vous savez dans l'est dans les
entretiens d'embauché ou dans les
castings pour nous autres comédiens
immanquablement on vous pose cette
question quels sont les défauts et les
qualités qui vous définissent le mieux
bon alors les défauts ça y'a pas de
problème on en trouve toujours
mais des qualités on a toujours une
pudeur plus ou moins feintes qui nous
empêche d'annoncer la couleur est bien
pour moi il ya jamais eu de problème
c'est vrai d'abord pour les défauts 1
ont validé tout de suite le problème
j'en ai pas ou alors j'en ai trop et il
faudrait plus d'une conférence tedx pour
en faire le tour
mais par contre des qualités je sais que
j'en ai une depuis toujours je suis
curieux de tout pour tous et surtout en
ce qui concerne mon environnement
immédiat
je peux pas m'empêcher de me poser des
questions
qu'est ce qui se cache derrière le nom
de cette station de métro qu'est ce qui
se cache derrière le nom cette rue
qu'est ce qui se cache derrière cet
immeuble qu'en at il été construits qui
l'a habité
pourquoi paris était la capitale de la
france pourquoi d'ailleurs paris
s'appelle-t-elle paris voilà tout un
ensemble de questions que je me pose en
permanence qui me pousse à cause de
cette curiosité à mener des enquêtes et
du coup à partir sur les traces de
l'origine des racines de mon quotidien
et cette curiosité ces enquêtes
ça me projette dans des histoires des
histoires qui peuvent être anecdotique
mais qui peuvent être aussi emblématique
de ma réalité et de mon quotidien
et voilà toutes ces histoires qui me
donne la sensation de lever le voile sur
toutes les ombres qui m'entourent et de
peut-être appréhender un peu mieux la
réalité autour de moi voilà que j'ai la
sensation avec cette curiosité de vivre
dans une réalité plus éclairés dans une
réalité augmentée j'ai la sensation de
de dominer 7
cette réalité autour de moi d'en faire
quelque chose de moins passif
2 - banal de moins informels de moins
anecdotique 2 - quelconque pour au
contraire la transformer ma réalité mes
expériences quotidiennes en un voyage
incroyable à la rencontre de récits
merveilleux extraordinaire et de
personnages sublime qui ont peuplé cette
histoire pour façonner ma réalité la
réalité
voilà donc ce voyage au pays demain
réalité augmentée sur les ailes de ma
curiosité que j'ai envie de partager
avec vous parce que vous savez j'ai la
sensation moi de vivre comme septembre
cet enfant dans le film avec bruce
willis vous savez sixième sens qui se
penche vers lui et qui lui dit je vois
des gens qui sont morts ben moi c'est
pareil
autour de moi je vois des gens qui sont
morts je vois des choses qui ont existé
qui ne sont plus mais qu'ils ont face et
façonné ma réalité donc
suivez moi dans cette expérience de
réalité augmentée qui j'espère comme
pour moi vous permettra de savourer un
peu plus que les autres
votre quotidien et par là de vous sentir
peut-être un peu plus en décalage
alors attention il va falloir être très
précis parce que tout est vraiment très
précis tout a commencé très exactement
le mardi 27 octobre 1983 à 20h30 sur le
canal 3 de la télévision française
je regardais une émission présentée par
un chanteur eddy mitchell
cette émission s'appelait la dernière
séance on y voyait des westerns des
péplums d épopée commencée à la sauce
hollywoodienne qui nous parlait de robin
des bois des vikings d'ivanhoe de
guillaume le conquérant de ben-hur des
dix commandements etc etc
j'adorais ça j'enregistre et tout pour
pouvoir le lendemain refaire le scénario
avec mes soldats dans ma chambre
ou alors dans ma salle de bain quand il
s'agissait de faire traverser la mer
rouge à moïse avec mon super pleymo dans
mon lavabo
oui vous savez quand on est enfant on a
toujours un super jouer un jouet qui
meurt jamais et à qui on file les plus
beaux rôles donc là c'est évidemment
monde super mais les mots qui jouait le
rôle de modeuse moïse mais quand ma
maman m'a expliqué que toutes ces
histoires que j'adorais regarder la télé
à la télé étaient pour la plupart
d'entre elles mêmes fantasmes et
fictionné issus de notre histoire de
notre humanité de notre civilisation
alors je me suis plongé dans les manuels
ouah j'ai suivi des gens comme un ado
comme dans les romans historiques j'ai
suivi victor hugo j'ai suivi alexandre
dumas et là ma réalité a explosé je
pense que c'est le plus beau cadeau
cette manière de percevoir les manuels
d'histoire comme un un moyen de
d'alimenter mon imaginaire et de mieux
décrypter ainsi commencé à percevoir la
réalité autour de moi ça a été le plus
beau cadeau qu'ils aient pu faire là la
providence car à partir de ce moment le
monde a changé pour moi vraiment j'ai eu
la sensation de de partir à la recherche
de l'île au trésor
sans quitter le coin de ma rue
d'ailleurs comme premier voyage sur les
ailes de ma curiosité au pays de ma
réalité augmentée que je pourrais vous
proposer ce serait de vous raconter mon
déménagement à paris à 15 ans dans ma
rue justement qui s'appelait la rue de
la reine blanche alors la rue de la
reine blanche
c'est une rue sans relief une rue
quelconque du xiiie arrondissement de
paris
lui-même un arrondissement quelconque
mais ma rue s'appelait la rue de la
reine blanche
est ce que vous savez pourquoi ma rue
s'appelait la rue de la reine blanche ce
que quelqu'un le sait
et bien parce qu'autrefois à la fin du
xiiie siècle cette rue conduisait à un
château un château qui s'était fait
construire la veuve de saint louis
marguerite de provence pour y finir ses
jours le long de la rivière de bièvre
qui courait dans le xiiie arrondissement
et c'est aussi dans ce château que sa
fille blanche ira finir sa vie au début
du 14e siècle vous rendez compte
ma rue tout pourri du xiiie
arrondissement qui me conduit à l'école
au boulot aux impôts ou chez le
boulanger tout d'un coup elle me conduit
au moyen-âge elle me conduit chez saint
louis au temps des croisades des
chevaliers de jérusalem de la personne
des choux des formidables c'est
incroyable ça a pris une épaisseur une
dimension pas possible excusez moi là je
sèche très égoïste je vous parle de mon
expérience personnelle mais on pourrait
parler de vous un petit peu
qu'est ce qui se cache derrière la ville
où nous nous trouvons ce soir qu'est ce
qui se cache derrière le nom de reims je
pense que quelqu'un c'est quand même
c'est une tribu l'ereem une tribu
gauloise
alors ça y est la race commence à
prendre du relief vous trouvez pas on
commence à s'animer là les droïdes les
forêts des chaînes vercingétorix alésia
les gaulois non
ont fait l'histoire c'est magnifique on
brise dans le temps mais excusez moi
mais des tribus gauloises comme les
rênes sous l'antiquité il n'a plus d'une
centaine il ya des tacles en gaulois qui
d'ailleurs passe le temps à passent leur
temps à se prêter entre eux donc c'est
pas si original que ça sauf que il ya
une autre histoire légendaire autour du
nom de reims une légende
la légende de romulus et rémus oui
mesdames et messieurs les rémois on va
parler de rome à reims de la cité
éternelle
les fondateurs de rome cette grande cité
dont on est les héritiers rome a été
fondée par deux frères
selon la légende romulus et rémus après
ses deux frères jumeaux ils ont fini par
se friter donc romulus a tué ou fait
tuer remus et ses soldats sont partis en
exil ont été bannis se sont sauvés ils
ont foutu le camp et il aurait créé
reims figurez vous alors c'est une
légende c'est une légende qui datent du
haut moyen-âge mais romulus et rémus
c'est aussi une légende la réalité par
deux légendes les légendes sont le
substrat notre réalité historique et
reims du coup se retrouvent affiliés
directement à l' empire
voilà peut-être pourquoi après la chute
de l'empiré romain d'occident 476 clovis
a été baptisé sacrés à reims
voilà pourquoi à travers toute
l'histoire de france jusqu'à jeanne
d'arc qui va les faire sacrer charles
vii à reims pourquoi c'est dangereux
non c'est à reims parce que reims quand
le rhum a chuté en 476 l' empire romain
dont les mérovingiens les carolingiens
se voulait les héritiers un les
continuateurs de rome
clovis comme charlemagne se voulait
empereur quelque part et bien voilà
pourquoi ça s'est passé à reims vous
rendez compte de l'épaisseur de reims
d'un coup là la densité reims est mille
fois plus importante que paris au
moyen-âge mille fois plus importante
part il va rentrer dans l'histoire que
en pro 4e siècle avec julia qui sifflent
couronne emprunt c'est une autre
histoire
restons sur reims et ce nom qui
maintenant n'est plus un nom banal
quelconque artificiel mais qui vous
invite à une belle histoire une histoire
captivante sans doute légendaire
mythique mais fondatrice de cette
réalité qui fera que les royaux le
royaume de france et les rois de france
se feront sacrée à deux pas d'ici
mais ce petit voyage amusant j'espère
divertissant il faut le prendre comme
tel
eh bien on le fait pour les noms des
lieux paris reims la rue darren blanche
mais on pourrait aussi bien le faire
pour le nom des choses pour les mots et
oui les mots aussi c'est pas des
accidents passive sans relief
eux aussi ils ont une histoire à vous
raconter pour peu que vous voyez bien
l'oreille les mots c'est le formule que
j'aime employer les mots sont des
monuments dans nos bouches à chaque fois
que vous parlez un manque ablement vous
allait convoquer un ancêtre vous assure
on va prendre un petit exemple de mots
qui va vous raconter une histoire des
mots proche de nous les mois de notre
calendrier janvier février mars avril
mai juin juillet août septembre je vous
ai dit c'est dur north en octobre
novembre décembre
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent dire ces -
qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière le mot
janvier et bien si on n'y prête
l'oreille si on a un petit peu curieux
vous allez vous rendre compte que
derrière cette succession de moi qui
défilent tout au long de l'année
et bien c'est l'histoire de notre
civilisation qui vous étreint qui va
vous est racontée
oui mesdames et messieurs je vous le
prouve janvier mot latin dieu romain
dieu très anciens janus un dieu double
le dieu des portes et des fermetures d
ouverture des fermetures c'est pour ça
qu'on a placé janus janvier au début de
l'année
c'est lui qui ouvre l'année et c'est lui
qui ferme l'ancien c'est un dieu
animiste vous savez au tout début de
notre humanité
quand on n'avait pas encore d'ingénieurs
de techniciens de savants on expliquer
le monde par les forces magiques divine
y avait des dieux partout il y avait des
dieux dans les fauteuils dans les
coussins dans les feuilles d'arbres dans
le ciel dont l'intérieur était dieu
partout on comprenait rien à rien
c'était des dieux voilà pour nous aider
à comprendre la nature la nature qui
nous écrase la nature qui qui est au
dessus de nous qui joue avec nous d'où
le deuxième mois février februar le mois
des fièvres des frimas le petit homme
tout à poil qu'au début la civilisation
il tremble il a peur et comprend rien à
rien il se fait écraser miss france ce
lien par un tsunami par un ouragan bref
c'est le début lily est pourtant il est
pas très fort mais heureusement arrive
mars mars
encore un mot latin encore un dieu le
dieu de la guerre
attention là on quitte l'état de nature
l'homme veut prendre en main son destin
il part à la conquête bon c'est encore
par la force pourrait encore dans l'état
de nature
donc il y va avec son gourdin et il veut
domestique et le monde mais mars n'est
plus un dieu animiste c'est déjà le dieu
d'un état la conquête assentiment un
caractère on avance
arrive ensuite avril avril c'est
aphrodite
alors c'est encore un dieu d'une pulsion
primaires comme la guerre la force de la
volonté de puissance de l'homme puisque
c'est la déesse de la sexualité
l'instinct de reproduction de
conservation bref
vraiment comme le dirait nietzsche da la
base des caractères profond qui nous
anime nous frères humains qui vivons
tous ensemble mais une petite
particularité c'est que aphrodite est
une déesse grecque
jusqu'à présent c'était que des mots
latins et bien ça nous renseigne aussi
sur l'histoire de notre civilisation
80% des mots que j'emploie sont issus de
la civilisation gréco-latine 80% pour
les latins 10% pour le grec le reste ce
n'est que 10 % de la réalité des mots
qu'on emploie nous sommes issus de cette
civilisation là et ça le vous le voyez
dans le calendrier
arrive ensuite un autre mot latin mais
maya déesse de la fertilité et arrivent
ensuite junon déesse latine mort aux
mains encore une fois mais cette fois-ci
déesse du mariage alors là tout change
j'ai l'impression de me revoir à 20 en
philo en suivant des cours où nos profs
nous disait avec jean jacques rousseau
dans le contrat social
quand l'homme quitte l'état de nature
pour fonder une société
le mariage c'est pas autre chose voilà
premier pacte social l'homme a décidé de
gouverner
l'ordre des choses de prendre en charge
et le prendre en main la gouvernance du
monde il va commencer à sa suter
s'associer en société et quitter cet été
des états de nature qui lui faisait tant
peur et qui n'expliquait auparavant que
par des forces divines ou surnaturel où
la nature toute puissante en parlant
d'hommes la suite de notre calendrier va
montrer à quel point il prend toute la
place puisque juillet et août sont des
mois dédié à des empereurs juillet jules
césar août
auguste et oui cette fois ci ça y est
l'homme se débarrasse un peu de dieu
quoi que jules césar et auguste était
aussi des demi dieux avaient été
divinisé mais c'est vraiment l'homme qui
prend les commandes et on le voit à la
suite septembre octobre novembre
décembre des mots latins là encore
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent dire 7 8 9 10
ça y est l'homme résonne l'homme avance
place à la technique à la science pour
expliquer le monde
on l'a quitté leeds nature on a quitté
les dieux on a quitté les forces à lima
les forces terrestres énergétique et
viva et comment il est vital de la
nature animée maintenant c'est l'homme
qui résonne c'est lorsque c'est l'homme
qui prend le contrôle mais vous n'êtes
pas mariée qui est un truc qui cloche
7 8 9 10 septembre cette pourtant je
crois que c'était le neuvième mois de
l'année octobre 8 pourtant je croyais
que c'était le dixième mois de l'année
je suis ni à 27 octobre novembre 9
pourtant c'est le onzième mode lan et
décembre
pourtant c'est le douzième mois de
l'année qu'est ce que c'est que ce bazar
qui est-ce qui a déréglé la mécanique
et bien c'est l'homme c'est jules césar
c'est auguste qui se sont intercalés
dans notre calendrier qu'on foutu le
bordel
bon en même temps il faut les comprendre
ils n'allaient pas choisir novembre
février les mecs ils sont mis qui sont
choisis des beaux mois d'été où il fait
beau toute l'année on fait l'apéro et
ces jeunes cesare grand chose alors
attendez c'est les politiques les mecs
sains et choisissent les bons mois donc
cette petite histoire elle et elle et
elle est très schématique mais elle
résume bien l'histoire de notre
civilisation
et surtout elle montre bien à quel point
l'homme a été capable du meilleur mais
aussi capable du pire en déréglant les
choses qu'il a lui-même savamment réglé
voilà alors je veux certainement pas
faire de morale quand on aime l'histoire
comme je le lis comme c'est mon cas on
le fait de manière purement
divertissante captivante pour chercher
de belles histoires
et pour agrémenter l'ordinaire savez je
suis persuadé qu en étant curieux comme
je le suis depuis toujours
ça permet de de réenchanter la vie
d'améliorer un quotidien qui d'un coup
devient enchantée qui explose un peu
comme ces livres animés vous savez les
pop up ça saute dans tous les sens et je
pense très honnêtement que ce
questionnement ce bonheur il est dans le
point d'interrogation dans le fait de se
poser des questions vous savez quand
j'étais en philo j'étais jusqu'en
licence
excusez-moi pas mal merci
non mais aujourd'hui ça s'appelle un
master ce que je pense que quand on
disait ouais je suis licencié de
philosophie
ça veut dire que tu t'es fait virer non
non aux licenciés licence donc
maintenant dit un master 1 mètre c'est
plus sérieux je je suis très
pompeusement fier d'être titulaire d'un
master de philosophie
bref nos profs nous disait la
philosophie c'est surtout pas chercher
des points finaux la philosophie c'est
chercher des hypothèses ne concluez
jamais rien essayer de combattre vos
certitudes rester dans la thermos dans
les interrogations c'est socrates avec
la fameuse phrase du tout ce que je sais
c'est que je ne sais rien c'est le doute
cartésien
c'est ça la philosophie apprendre à
rester en éveil finalement c'est
apprendre à rester avec sa capacité
d'émerveillement d'être stupéfié ses
continuer à regarder le monde avec des
yeux d'enfants et la seule chose que
j'ai envie de vous dire si vous faites
comme moi vous vous sentirez un peu plus
jeune je vous assure
cultivez vos pourquoi c'est le meilleur
moyen d'affronter la vie et je vous
assure de lutter contre la mort merci
[Applaudissements]